all right what's going on guys this is
rob and i got a tweet that i need to
specify here right basically gives us
this kind of depiction of like who the
illuminati basically are
in uh in in doctor strange two now
again i need to specify
this is just rumor and conjecture
nothing's been confirmed the only real
confirmation we have or seen seemingly
confirmation we have when it comes to
the illuminati is the voice of what
sounds like professor xavier although i
mean hell at this point right multiverse
of madness it could just be jean-luc
picard from star trek right you know the
borg or the cause of all of this doctor
strange you know who knows
i mean it is probably professor xavier
but that's really where i want to start
here right i want to kind of run over
who i imagine these members of the
illuminati are so the first one on this
tweet that i was given right this this
dm that i was given is professor charles
xavier specifically from the days of
future past timeline now here's the
thing right here's here's here's bear
with me here right bear with me
i know a lot of you guys are going to be
like no that's ridiculous the days of
future past timeline doesn't exist
anymore that's true
kind of so here's the thing right now
that the fox properties are owned by
disney it means we're not playing by the
fox universe rules anymore we're playing
by the rules of the marvel multiverse
now the big difference between the way
fox handled things and the way that
marvel handles things is fox essentially
had linear time marvel has the whole
multiverse i mean fox kind of had the
multiverse in this sense that it's like
a fantastic four movie here and we're
really a couple of fantastic four movies
here right so like the original cast and
then the one with michael b jordan and
kate mara and all them and then like the
x-men movies and so on and so forth but
you guys get what i'm saying right the
idea of a multiverse existing in fox was
more due to circumstance as opposed to
anything actually being organized and
planned out and us being told like
there's a multiverse and the fantastic
four in the universe and the x-men are
in this universe and so on and so forth
right this is kind of a hodgepodge of
things but when you look at the idea of
linear time right this is like if you
right now went back to when bitcoin was
first introduced to the world and
invested a thousand dollars then when
you come back to the modern day you're
going to be like a billionaire or a
trillionaire right the past directly
affects the present when it comes to the
multiverse that's not necessarily true
assuming that the marvel cinematic
universe follows the marvel comics model
for the multiverse which there's no
nothing to guarantee that it does what
you have is basically branch universe
theory for every possibility that exists
there exists a universe for it so if you
went back in time and you invested a
thousand dollars in bitcoin when bitcoin
first showed up when you came back to
the present day you would basically just
still be yourself which is the reason
why you went back in time in the first
place your actions in investing a
thousand dollars in bitcoin when it was
first introduced created an alternate
reality where you became a billionaire
in that alternate reality because you
invested in bitcoin now again we don't
know exactly how the multiverse works in
the mcu even in no way home dr strange
said we know virtually nothing about it
i think we'll learn a lot about it in
doctor strange the multiverse of madness
and i think the illuminati will be the
ones to give it to us but at the end of
the day the big question you kind of
have to ask here is if it is professor
xavier from days of future past and that
days of future past timeline is
basically destroyed then how in the
world do you end up with professor
xavier from days of future past
and doctor strange to multiverse of
madness i think the answer to that
is from spider-man no way home now i
don't mean to say that like professor
xavier is one of the people who knew
peter parker was spider-man and he was
yanked into the universe because of the
spell that went awry between peter and
doctor strange what i mean to say here
is when you look at spider-man no way
home what was the explanation that was
given to us in terms of how it is that
green goblin and electro and sandman and
the lizard and dr octopus were all in
that movie the answer is that they were
plucked out of their own universes now
the truth is that because the spell went
awry and because doctor strange wasn't
able to close it off in time that they
were able to make an end where most
everybody else was essentially kept out
the question i would ask here is what's
the difference between that and someone
just appearing to you and saying we need
your help and that's what i think was
going on when it came to professor
xavier assuming this idea that it is him
from the days of future past timeline
and so using that basis it's entirely
possible that what was basically going
on here is that the days of future pass
timeline is an actual collapsed dead
timeline whether the mcu decides to
borrow from marvel comics and say that
that universe that timeline was just
kind of shuffled off to the far shore
where universes go to die or just simply
cease to exist is actually irrelevant
here borrowing from spiderman no way
home it's not that far outside the realm
of possibility that in that scene from
x-men days of future past when the
sentinels break in and their i-beams are
getting ready to blast everybody and
magneto and xavier and kitty pride and
wolverine's body on the table and i
think bobby drake was there right in
that moment when they're all getting
ready to die before they disappear
somebody shows up and grabs professor
xavier now this i think gives us the
second member of the illuminati and one
that seems also a pretty obvious choice
here and i would say that's baron mordo
the reason being is that baron mordo
very much follows the rules baron mordo
is a person who does not believe in
arbitrarily adjusting the timeline in
order to fit personal gain like
literally he wouldn't shut up about it
and doctor strange won and kept yelling
at stephen strange about breaking the
rules for his own personal gain and so
on and so forth and so you have to
believe that if someone appears at the
end of the days of future past timeline
and grabs professor xavier before the
timeline basically comes to an end
whoever appears there would have to have
the ability to stop time otherwise they
would end up there just in time to see
everyone die or disappear right so it's
not that far outside the realm for baron
mordo to appear and to basically freeze
time and then tell xavier we need you
like we need your help with what's going
on out there in the multiverse different
things along those lines now why it is
that he would pick charles xavier of all
people doesn't really matter we don't
really care right it's just we would get
charles xavier from the x-men in days of
future past so they could give us the
most nonsensical hand-wavy explanation
where baron mordo is like i've been
looking through the multiverse professor
xavier and i'm just i'm just enamored by
your bald head and i figured you'd be a
great member of the illuminati and we
would be like that's awesome right who
cares we have xavier in the movie and
that's all we really care about but in
terms of why baron mordo would pick that
version of charles xavier that would
actually make a lot more sense remember
baron mortal cares about the rules baron
mordo does not believe in bending the
rules changing time for his own personal
gain if the days of future past timeline
is basically a collapsed dead timeline
that that timeline is effectively going
to end that version of charles xavier is
simply going to cease to exist then it's
not breaking any rules he's not like
screwing up the multiverse by showing up
to a version of xavier who's about to
cease to exist in like 30 seconds and
then saying hey man we need your help
don't worry your timeline is going to be
saved this every everything is good
wolverine basically finished the job
mystique didn't kill ball of our trask
everything's compacted things are going
to go back to the way that they're
supposed to be your timeline is going to
die we need your help and he basically
plucks xavier out of his own timeline
and then brings him in as part of the
illuminati no real rules are broken
there's no damage going on with the
multiverse because it's not like days of
future past continues on that universe
is dead it's gone it's out of the
picture right so there's there's no real
need for it right it's like it's like
stealing a radio from a car that you're
about to destroy no one's gonna miss it
[Laughter]
no one's gonna come looking for it right
so these other pics really seem to fall
in line largely with what we've seen
over the mcu or closer in line with like
the nature of the comics so if we say
that like baron mordo from the maine
marvel cinematic universe is the second
member of the illuminati outside of
charles xavier and in fact baron moto's
really more the first because he's the
one rounding people up then while
charles xavier is brought in for
whatever reason makes sense his
expertise on mutants i guess i don't
know probably something to do with like
scarlet witch or what have you that the
next person to grab would probably be
reed richards now again my pick here is
john krasinski and i kind of i kind of
reference back to our our trailer
breakdown video where i say one of the
things that the fantastic four are best
known for is charting the multiverse
more specifically than that being able
to look in to alternate realities right
being able to look into alternate
universes and basically give us these
different depictions and see how things
transpired right having what's called
the bridge reed richards has the
intelligence to do that if you're the
illuminati and you are basically wanting
to understand what's going on with the
madness of the multiverse but like you
don't want to go in there and have to
deal with that craziness then sure you
would construct a window right it's
basically like there's just some giant
riot or some giant fight going on inside
of a grocery store there's a pretty good
chance you won't actually go into the
store but you would do like most people
and just look through the window and
watch all that insanity unfold that's
basically what the bridge is right so
having reed richards would be a great
person to bring in in order to achieve
that in order to basically say you need
to construct a bridge into the
multiverse so we can actually see what's
going on there again why he's choosing
reed richards who knows who cares right
i mean it could be anybody who could do
this but technically reed is the
smartest person in the entirety of any
universe in marvel comics like it
doesn't matter what universe it is in
any alternate reality universe it
doesn't matter the main marvel universe
alternate universes whatever read is
always the smartest guy technically it's
reed dr doom and then reed's daughter
valeria who kind of alternate these
three places but the next person here
and this is one that's particularly
interesting would be captain carter now
apparently captain carter is a really
popular choice right now for the
illuminati one that a lot of people are
really co-signing on is like a person
who is officially part of the team and
in reality it makes sense the idea of
captain carter being in the illuminati
really seems to be more based on
circumstance as opposed to like anything
intrinsically valuable about her
character the first circumstance is that
as far as we're aware chris evans is
like i'm done with captain america at
least for right now or unless marvel
cuts me a fat enough check uh but like
i'm i'm taking a break from like this
this whole thing with the marvel
cinematic universe that only really
leads uh leaves peggy carter because of
the what if episode now in the what if
episode of course as you guys saw she
basically ended up traveling through
that portal and
essentially killed whatever that demonic
beast happened to be but the ability to
face off against that kind of threat and
succeed would really seem to indicate
like fortitude and perseverance
confidence that kind of a thing the kind
of attributes you would look for in
what's really like a natural leader able
to garner forces the funny thing about
this though is that when it came to the
illuminati the bigger role that was
played when it came by captain america
under jonathan hickman's avengers new
avengers is that he was the voice of
reason right he was the one that would
basically bring people back and calm
people down the biggest issue you have
here though is that at that point in
time xavier was dead he was killed in
avengers versus x-men and xavier was
normally the voice of reason and that's
what we would expect right we would
expect charles xavier to play the voice
of reason so why peggy carter would be
there other than the fact that like hey
it's captain carter cool i don't really
know right i'm not 100 sure uh but
moving beyond her we go into superior
iron man now i am a big fan of the
rumors that tom cruise is playing
superior iron man i imagine just the
name is gonna piss off a lot of people
where he's like i'm the superior iron
man and the reason why i think it's
gonna piss off a lot of people is
because i imagine they're gonna be like
so that's basically tom cruise saying
he's a better iron man than robert
downey jr but honestly it's a genius
marketing move by the marvel cinematic
universe if they do that because that's
gonna have people talking i mean i can
imagine the twitter hashtags right now
right hashtag team stark
team cruise right people who are like
who is really the better iron man iron
man's exceedingly popular so introducing
an alternate reality counterpart to our
to iron man and then calling him the
superior iron man
it really is going to create a lot of
discussion not only that from what we've
seen at least in terms of the rumors and
whatnot tom cruise having three of the
infinity stones tom cruise successfully
turning the ultron ai into really like
the whole suit of armor around the world
idea actually being able to create the
iron legion the way it was supposed to
exist all of that would really point to
the idea that he is actually a better
iron man at least in terms of him being
able to do the things he was supposed to
do or wanted to do then essentially tony
stark right robert downey jr's iron man
right again that's kind of up for debate
but the more important thing here in
terms of why he would be part of the
illuminati is that tony stark is well
known to be what's called a futurist
that most people think about the present
day right read richard's whole idea for
example is he wants to solve the problem
of everything right like everything
wrong with the world i want to solve
that hence the reason why he created the
future foundation the reason why he
temporarily joined the council of reeds
all that kind of stuff tony stark
doesn't care about any of that so a
really good example here is that when
the incursion started and jonathan
hickman's avengers new avengers tony
stark right off the bat knew there was
no conceivable way that they could
basically stop the collapse of the
multiverse analyzing all the variables
all the odds he knew there was no way
that could be done but what he also
realized is that people needed hope and
they needed a distraction that's the
reason why he got with captain america
and created avengers world where
basically they would unite all these
different superheroes around the world
into one giant avengers team and they
would all basically fight different
threats and so on and so forth in their
parts of the world right big hero 6 out
in japan alpha flight out in canada
right any of the other teams that exist
here in the united states and it was
just one great big huge distraction it
would also mean that if captain america
is doing that he wouldn't be thinking
about what tony stark's doing why he's
missing for like three months at a time
when in reality he's out gallivanting
around with the illuminati but the truth
is that he was just like there's no way
for us to win he knew that before it all
started but he just kind of let
everybody go through the motions because
it was better than everybody just giving
up and just letting everything die right
everything he did creating the dyson
sphere right literally harnessing the
power of the sun that it was all
basically a useless effort and he knew
it was and so that's what makes tony
stark so significant that's why he would
be such a great asset on the illuminati
is because he thinks about what's coming
50 steps down the road whereas most
everybody is thinking about what's
happening in the here and now now the
next thing to go the next person that
was really brought in with this and this
is a really really interesting one and
probably one that i think is going to
incite a lot of debate here is basically
maria rambo now the other part of that
is i've heard that it could be monica
rambo basically a variant of her that
instead of becoming spectrum ended up
becoming captain marvel i would say that
if that's the direction that they're
going with it's a variant of captain
marvel it would stand more to reason
that it's maria rambo because maria was
around at the time that carol became
captain marvel right she was just she
wasn't necessarily in that exact picture
per se but she was part of it to a
degree right they were operating at the
exact same time so events basically
transpired a little bit different and
maria rambo ended up becoming captain
marvel it could also be that while maria
rambo was captain marvel she passed her
powers down to her daughter so instead
of instead of monica becoming like
spectrum she ended up becoming uh
becoming captain marvel instead right
inherited her mother's powers that's
happened multiple times in marvel comics
not specifically with carol danvers
because the only time she ever had a kid
is when basically immortus an alternate
version of kang gave birth to himself
through her yeah it's ever been as weird
as you think it sounds like it i promise
you it is it was a weird and pretty
badly written story from avengers number
200 but nonetheless it would make more
sense that this would be maria as
opposed to monica but regardless it also
fits like the depiction of the person
that we saw who was facing off against
the scarlet witch now again people are
still saying that it's entirely possible
it's tony stark honestly it's difficult
to tell rumors are still circulating
around which i'm becoming a little more
of a fan of that it's some alternate
version of kane the conqueror it doesn't
really matter but when it comes to the
last two members here these are
particularly interesting the first one
is basically a variant of black bold of
the inhumans i can't really envision
why they would have him there outside of
the fact that
black bolt was a member of the
illuminati in the comics the reality
here is that in both the inhumans
terrible show that we got that i watched
one episode of and was like nope and
then turned it off and then like in the
comics black bolt doesn't really serve a
useful purpose the only time black bolt
was ever important in marvel comics was
him when he became like the leader of
the cree race and then went to war with
uh vulcan who was like this ridiculously
powerful brother of cyclops of the x-men
and they tore a hole in space and then
eventually the cancer verse came out
black bolt has never mattered the guy
can't talk right the guy never talks i
mean he has what's called a quasi-sonic
scream so if he speaks it would
basically eradicate everything depending
on what era of comics you're reading and
his voice is powerful enough to just
destroy an entire planet and other times
it can just make people's ears bleed for
a while so like it just it's it's super
inconsistent so i don't really know why
you know he's even considered here as a
possibility for a member of the
illuminati but more so than that what's
also really interesting is that there
are people who are circulating around
rumors saying that it's potentially
balder the brave or somebody like
magneto as interesting as those would be
i don't really see them introducing
someone who is by all standards of
measurement as as obscure as balder the
brave is unless you're ridiculously
familiar with the asgardian mythos
whether here in the real world or in
comics you're probably not going to know
who bald or the brave is unless you
played baldur's game that was a really
good game back today but you're not
really going to know who balder who
baller the bravest you may have like
heard the name they would have to do a
pretty good chunk of explanation the
only way to really get around that is to
say that like he is the brother of thor
and he's actually the god of thunder in
some alternate reality duck right that's
the only way you could really get away
with it is to relate him to somebody
people are already familiar with and
then say he's a variant of that person
and then like that's basically it but
the last choice here is really the more
interesting and honestly i think this is
one that's really going to incite a lot
of debate again in case you guys have
because we haven't really mentioned it
for a little while but case you guys are
kind of lost track these are the rumors
that are circulating around out there
right so again none of this is really
absolute or written in concrete but the
the final person that seems to be a
relatively popular choice for the
illuminati
is black panther
played by michael b jordan now here's
the thing right here's the thing
i could see this being the case and for
a couple different reasons right so the
first thing is that the way he's
depicted here is that he is depicted in
the black and gold outfit that we saw in
the first black panther movie but one of
the other things to understand is that
michael b jordan would not be playing a
variant of eric killmonger he would be
playing a variant of t'challa meaning he
would be the son of t'chaka the rightful
heir to the role of the black panther
i'll be honest with you guys
this seems cool it seems really really
really really cool in terms of why they
choose this version the most obvious
answer here is they can't use a variant
of chadwick boseman the reality is that
it's just too early to know whether or
not that would be acceptable the only
way to know whether or not they could
use like cgi to basically digitally
recreate the face of chadwick boseman
would be to see how people respond to
whatever it is they end up doing in
black panther one right it's a very
tedious and a very very a very touchy
situation right this is one of those
things when it comes to the whole idea
of like chadwick boseman black panther
you're quite literally walking a knife
stage make one false step and it all
comes crashing down right remember
social media loves to be angry right
they absolutely adore the concept of
being pissed off and so having that
opportunity to be angry because of how
something was handled incorrectly in
black panther people would be over the
moon for that right they're just laying
in weight licking their lips for for the
chance to be upset and so having to walk
that sort of tightrope is is something
that is exceedingly difficult to do and
so if they're going to give us a
depiction of black panther played by
somebody other than chadwick boseman
using an alternate reality variant is
the best way to do it it's the absolute
best way to do it because they can test
bet it in a very very easy and
dismissible way right so if they're just
kind of like okay uh you know like
people aren't really receptive to
michael b jordan you know then it's kind
of like all right i mean the movie's
already shot they can't make a whole lot
of changes you know that's basically it
um and then we never see or hear from
him again right or something along those
lines right he just never ever
referenced and that's basically it
whereas if people are receptive to the
idea of someone other than chadwick
boseman playing the role of t'challa
then suddenly you basically end up
having a situation where they basically
recast chadwick boseman or recast
t'challa as someone other than chadwick
boseman in terms of any future
depictions of black panther in the
marvel cinematic universe so with that
being said guys uh these are the kind of
rumors and honestly these are my picks
when it comes to the the illuminati and
the marvel cinematic universe i agree
with some of these choices don't we
agree with the idea of black well black
bolt sucks that guy doesn't matter no
one cares about black bolt black bolt
doesn't even care about black belt
marvel doesn't even care like no one
cares about black bolt right like if god
exists god forgot he made black ball i
mean the guy doesn't matter right the
guy's just totally irrelevant and and
like literally if we were in that movie
and like the guy just had a building
fall on him and was just totally
destroyed no one would care they would
be like all right cool whatever man or
it could very well be that like the
marvel cinematic universe makes black
bolt the coolest he's ever been right
maybe he's super badass like he wasn't
house of him when he basically whispered
and wiped out like a mile like a square
mile of land it was nuts like he
literally just whispered and just
annihilated he was so op in the house of
him storyline it was ridiculous how
broken he was but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
let me know down in the comment section
what you guys think about these
different pics and uh yeah
i will catch you all later
peace